hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
a plane intersects a cylinder through
its axis in the shape of a rectangle
what is the radius of the cylinder such
that the cylinder has maximum volume and
the rectangle has a perimeter of 9
centimeters
a similar problem was asked in an
international test of 17 and 18 year old
students who had taken calculus
with an average of only 30 percent
answering correctly
it was one of the harder problems on the
test
the tests did include five multiple
choice answers but to make things
challenging i'm omitting any answer
choices
can you figure this problem out
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution
so how can we solve this problem
to get started let's label this diagram
the top and bottom sides of the
rectangle
span the diameters of the circles
so their length will be equal to two
times the radius of each of these
circles
next the other sides of the rectangle
span the height of the cylinder
so we'll label these lengths as h
the perimeter of the rectangle is given
to be 9 and that equals 4r plus 2h
we can divide both sides by 2 to get h
is equal to 4.5 minus 2r
now the volume of a cylinder is equal to
pi r squared h
we can rewrite this in terms of r if we
substitute for the value of h
we then simplify this
and now we need to solve for the maximum
volume
to do that we'll take the derivative and
set it equal to zero
we get a quadratic equation
we can divide both sides by pi and then
factor
so there are two possible values for r
one possibility is that r is equal to
zero
in this case the volume will be equal to
0 so this must be a minimum
the other solution will be 1.5
and that's the answer the radius is
equal to 1.5 centimeters
this will be the rectangle that has a
perimeter of 9 and gives a maximum
volume to the cylinder
so once you set the problem up it's
pretty straightforward to solve it using
calculus
but what if you don't know calculus
well there is a way you can solve this
problem without calculus
it uses the arithmetic mean geometric
mean inequality
i did a video on this and you should
definitely check it out to understand
why this is true i'm just going to
present this inequality and use its
result for the rest of this video so
this states that for non-negative
numbers x1 to xn
the arithmetic mean is always greater
than or equal to the geometric mean
equality holds if and only if all
variables are equal to each other
now sometimes it helps to multiply both
sides by n
we have the sum of n numbers is greater
than or equal to n
times the nth root of the product of
those numbers
in this video we're going to deal with n
is equal to three so we have the sum of
three variables being greater than or
equal to three times the cube root of
the product of those variables with the
quality if and only if all variables are
equal to each other so what are the
three variables we're going to use
well the volume is equal to pi r squared
h so it seems like we only have two
variables
but we can get three variables by
writing r squared as r times r and we're
going to maximize the value of r times r
times h and that'll give us the maximum
volume
so the other condition is we have the
perimeter is equal to 9 which equals 4r
plus 2h
we divide by 2 to get 4.5 is equal to 2r
plus h
now once again we're going to do a
little trick
2r can be rewritten as r plus r plus h
so here we have the sum of three
variables and by the am gm inequality
this has to be greater than or equal to
three times the cube root of the product
of these three variables
we can then divide both sides by three
and then cube both sides to get 1.5
cubed is greater than or equal to r
times r times h
so if we maximize r times r times h
we'll get the maximum volume
this will happen if all variables are
equal to each other so the maximum
occurs if h is equal to r is equal to
1.5 and we immediately figure out that r
is equal to 1.5 is the value for the
radius
what's more is we've also figured out
the value of h
and we know the maximum volume will be
1.5 cubed times pi
so the amgm method is a little bit more
complicated but it produces some very
satisfying results that you can solve
for all of the variables and the maximum
volume pretty quickly
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on youtube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world
they have over 1 million views and the
channel has over 1 million subscribers
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos and email me a puzzle or
math topic presh mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise on teespring where you can
grab a mug or t-shirt you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon thanks for watching and thanks
for your support